like I said today I wanted to find
another random games play and I found
this game called fern bow it is
described as a trip to the deepest and
darkest side of the human mind delivered
through blood and tears and it's
supposed to be a very creepy
point-and-click adventure game so that
sounds right up my arm does not
represent the finished concept game or a
bra if you feel this game should be
finished please consider how yes get
this is done Co ok a mad journey awaits
us let's go let's get it ready
everything's fine
it feels like heaven her eyes
I see my parents
they look happy
they have a present for me I wonder
it's a cat so sweet and pretty dark as
the deepest night
I run a kitty it's mr. midlife hi sir
cute my best friend
my only friend
we're having dinner and I see our grace
- I really like you a lot
it's Friday my parents are going out I'm
grace
takes good care of me
we're having so much fun look at my cap
it's Monday night I'm playing with mr.
midnight but something feels real bad
oh that's donnie darko a strange
creature I thought my window I don't
like it it scares me suddenly I hear
something mr. big night protect her it's
mom
screaming I want to know what's wrong a
heavy light shines my parents room I go
closer oh she is what brave girl and
closer what is he doing to her mom mom
dad oh gosh
please don't why is she bleeding already
mommy daddy oh god that's awful
Oh oh dear
who's that hopeless hope mr. midnight
Fran please follow my voice to the count
of three you will wake up one two oh
she's in this like it's like it's like
her oh my gosh
I can't think of words Fran how do you
feel I feel like dying I think I'd say I
feel like dying because it's just not
nice is it I feel like dying I don't
someway we do this trying to counter
it's part of your cover
I'll try yes I'll try doctor that's a
positive attitude
I'm not in oh it is maybe I'm not bad
after all we did not use the word mad
here also she's like in a mental
hospital or whatever but now I've got
something for you Fran oh really
it's a cat through the desk there's a
little package for you it's a marked
grace take it oh I pray she's still in
contact that's nice is it this one here
Oh
open it there's something inside what is
it
um examined derp dearest friend here's
the pass you look do you like so much I
thought you would appreciate it
I was thinking of you that you like to
examine our protects and combine them
with other things I see what they're
doing here
never forget that creativity is the most
greatest gift you have love Aunt Grace
get me out of here our grace my cat just
live with you she's worried about you
I'm worried too because I'm not mad and
still here
stop it you're out of control young lady
oh sorry can I leave now yes you can
leave before you do it's time for your
new medicine what medicine it's called
your team it will make you feel very
relaxed nurse
how do they feed that's a little girl
anything new today doctor doctor Dean
nothing actually same visions as before
how I see here Fran take your medicine
yeah everybody take my medicine slap him
I don't feel good
she's gonna clap oh my gosh
what's the Maison du tout
Oh No take her back to her room ah that
was all your fault given a stupid
medicine and ass don't let her take this
ever again
yeah good cool beware Fran bow if you
leave the house of madness
I will hunt you catch you
and bring you back - its auntie Fran
wake up well mr. member the medicine
will help you escape I'll be waiting for
you in the forest Oh doc if they were
all right open cat I love you
so cute yay so buddy I'm still here
hideous place I have to get out of here
no you got a toy there that ain't too
bad
oh sweet sweet Matty locked good reason
to get curious yeah oh she's only ten
years old
oh poor girl the patient was found in
the Oswald asylum showing signs of
hallucination and depression the patient
is receiving treatment with dr. Darin
we have tried different medication and
all has been canceled because of side
effects
I see it see that oh holy moly something
fell and II hurt I'll save it to play
pirate later yeah that's good that's
more like a normal ten your girl does
hope this won't fall in my head while
I'm sleeping red and tiny are hiding
from me oh oh do I have to hide write
this down six H I have to find mr.
midnight I have to find him now I miss
my kitty he hides because he is afraid
he told me that the medicine will show
me where he is less is less is less his
equal number I hate the monster with the
mask okay that's weird
the mask I hate a muscle with the max oh
what's this oh I see okay so that's when
you can move rooms my legs are just fine
I'm not disabled okay yeah
hide what does that mean
abcdefg H that's eight all the darkness
tatemiya yeah yeah I got some pills
I don't worry mum knows oh what a missed
a hole so you having a good time I don't
think so
good night moon good night trees good
night dark dark night pillow
Oh God oh my god that's so creepy mom is
accelerating oh poor girl okay so
cynical Troy yeah oh Jesus
so scary oh right new this way okay a
secret box Shh teddy
I hope somebody loves you or my hemp do
you love your teddy hello boy
who are you I'm Phil everyone says that
I'm sick poor you due to the way out
yes the office is the key the office yes
the office you know where you meet the
doctor oh how do I get inside the office
he doesn't want me to tell you well darn
it who him
oh my god oh my god
so is he are controlling all of the kids
all doors are closed you are prisoner of
my games
and nobody will have escaped leave me
alone I hate you daddy I need you so
much right now
no I won't let that monster stop me
she's such a brave girl this one there
like this have a blue dress like yours
it's nice it is host nations
okay let's have a look in this vision oh
my god that is so creepy
oh Jesus Christ
Oh oh I heard he don't like that it
literally gives me shivers every single
time I press it I don't know what to do
okay okay that's cool right so know
what's inside then
a bobby pin oh what a picture oh look
it's our family and mr. midnight yay
okay let's see if this bowling pin works
it works in the films it fits but there
are two holes I need something else okay
what about this almost there but there's
another hole I need something else all
right I can bind them
don't be derpy okay do you get there
hello man hello sir can I ask you
something of course little girl what's
on your mind I need you to open the
yellow door for me why is that
because when Kass is outside sorry girl
even if I wanted to open it
I can its alarmed who cannot open it
then some people but there's a code and
that's almost impossible to find tell me
here is the code I won't tell you now
leave I'm reading here I'm fine
you talk to her more than I thought what
he would hey that's okey I'm listen girl
I can't reach it
damn it well you shouldn't we same damn
if you're a little girl what about this
hook you probably should use it with
something that you okay let's go to the
kitchen hey girl you look crazy
hello girl I can give you the max
magical stuff Shh
what magical stuff the magical stuff
that will make everything fall asleep
what do you mean here as a gift just
take it it's another pill isn't it yeah
is it to sleep also it's for me to go to
sleep then probably gonna use it on
someone else so I imagine I was probably
the guy outside for we give him think
it's a brain in his food Hey oh hello
Fran how are you today I see dead
animals I'm fine
glad to hear you're fine carry on now
yes can you open the other door that's
not very appropriate to ask I'll have to
ask you to leave to your room now
oh sorry miss I didn't mean say anything
inappropriate very well Fran go now
please you'll pay your friends everyone
is so mean here okay so I can combine
this with the sleeping pill yes I'm a
junior CPCB cake oh yeah okay what's in
the box
I love toys but nothing really
interesting or useful here oh my gosh he
is like mighty fat go away don't disturb
me I'm eating okay sorry
I want to take this don't touch my sword
I didn't know it was yours you should
bow and speak clearly to me I'm your
king oh really
what's your not the king
I am the very king of the whole universe
bow to me forget it hey hello the NASS
is dead
no she's not what nurse bloody me oh
bloody foodie don't eat it then but I'm
hungry
bloody me already war oh my gosh oh boy
you really have a disturbed mind
absolutely terrifying I don't want to
take my pills in this room because I'm
kind of scared about what the sky will
turn into of what he might be eating but
I think you guys probably want to see it
don't you
I'll just give this guy that doughnut
that looks tasty my child but I don't
want it what about you do you want my
doughnut I know what that you're uglier
I'm scared I think you said your looks
so hungry that you could eat blood okay
right
that's what else oh my gosh Lee nothing
okay let's go okay it's not actually
they are dead they're not theirs
just speaking to them I swear they're
not dead they're not dead so I'll take
it now oh my gosh I'm gonna have
nightmares tonight guys it's actually
really scary like I didn't think it
would be this scary
oh the super like vomit okay let's have
a look was in this room hide your pain
what is this the nurse is dead she's
holding something
she gets a headache and stuff
pink rope is mine now okay let's examine
this if you need to go out
turn off the alarm the door will open
one set the clock on the right time to
enter the code on the computer I got a
code C being brave pays off in the end
doesn't yeah okay can I combine that
with that yes I can some intelligent so
everywhere lot can I go to the toilet
that was creepy this room is empty
I didn't realize that anyone could see
me pooping gross I can and will hold it
okay fair enough
oh my god what if I do this are you guys
ready okay it's not that bad
the King likes to roaring I don't like
this oh my gosh what was that was that
indeed this game is so good I've got
chills right do you want my donut sir
yeah I don't know you're mean everyone
was mean I get to pitch it right do you
want mine done'
no one wants my donut it's pretty
annoying okay well what what if I bow to
him oh okay he's being civil
I want your king what walking King do
you mean my sword yes your highness
your sword what would you give me in
exchange
anything you need your highness
bring me a caster than a horse then
you'll get my sword ah yes a mean to me
Oh what if I draw it yeah it's such a
genius ah he's really happy so cute oh
that's beautiful exactly what I dreamt
her you can take my sword now it's yours
yay thank you sir how do I combine this
to death oh yeah okay grab my mattock go
go go
darn it and you give me that you can't
take that key I really need to open
office door please you can't I'll wait
until you leave then I will never leave
this chair
I will give you a doughnut then I hope
we can be friends I'm sorry Oh was that
it's a cake I thought you would like it
oh that's very kind of you thank you ah
yeah get the key get the gig get the
gear get that gig got the key core use
the cue to the others and we go okay
what happens here then set the clock on
right time I'm gonna forget this upper
register so I just go the clock all
right
right time
I don't friend well done yes very well
then okay when I came to [ __ ] jacking
weird alarm active end up in your
password IRA k36 oh I need to make it
forty gonna work sure work eventually if
I just hit buttons oh my gosh how do I
do this I don't understand
oh I do understand so 40
I just played but eventually there was
new tactics back oh yes I had the best
yes you are I don't we go off your pop
that was really good though I've enjoyed
that
thank you playing five of them liked it
these are our IndieGoGo campaign so I
thought I should be donating that wasn't
really funny game I mean like I've been
trying to find a game that takes me out
for a while more psychological and
there's meaning to it ya know I think
give me
Thursday you have died